un étudiant sur quatre rencontres des
difficultés à financer ses études malgré
les bourses les prêts bancaires les
petits boulots ça représente 600 mille
étudiants chaque année
ça vous choque nous aussi c'est pour ça
qu'avec zélie mon associé nous avons
décidé en janvier dernier de créer what
if community la première plateforme de
financement participatif dédié aux
études supérieures alors sur le papier
l'idée est prometteuse
après tout si on arrive à financer des
albums de musique ou une trottinette
électrique
pourquoi pas les un projet d'étude lors
du week-end de l'échappée en juin
dernier nous avions lancé notre
plateforme pilote avec trois étudiants
prometteurs pour financer leurs études
après quatre mois test eh bien ça ne
marche pas en confrontant l'idée au
terrain nous sommes rendu compte que les
étudiants n'avaient pas besoin de dons
ponctuels mais il avait besoin de voir
se projeter sur du long terme
on a compris que le crowdfunding ne
répondait ni au nombre important
d'étudiants en difficulté et n'était pas
ajustés aux besoins immenses en
financement être entrepreneur c'est
savoir se tromper ne pas avoir peur de
revenir sur son idée c'est s'adapter
l'enjeu du financement des études il est
là il est même beaucoup plus important
que ce que nous avions estimé
notre ambition est la même notre
solution est nouvelle pour ces étudiants
pour qui le financement est un frein à
la poursuite de leur cursus
nous inventons une offre non plus basée
sur le fait d'avoir un garant ou un
réseau mais fondée sur leur potentiel et
leur motivation
concrètement nous collectons des fonds
auprès d'entreprises et
d'institutionnels que nous mettons à la
disposition des étudiants
celui ci une fois diplômés s'engage à
reverser un pourcentage de son salaire
sur une période de temps donnée
individualisé à sa situation et à sa
formation
contrairement au prêt l'étudiant ne
rembourse que s'il en a la capacité et
selon ses moyens
pas de salaire pas de remboursement
s'ils gagnent moins que ce que nous
avions prévu
il rembourse moins que ce que nous lui
avons donné mais l inverse
s'ils gagnent plus que ce que nous
avions estimé il rembourse davantage et
nous permet de créer un système de
financement pérenne qui contribue à
financer d'autres étudiants alors ça
peut vous paraître un peu fou mais cette
solution elle existe déjà en allemagne
en amérique latine et elle a permis à
près de dix mille étudiants pauvres
d'accéder à l'université et pour nous le
financement des études n'est qu'un début
ce que nous souhaitons c'est ouvrir à
ses étudiants de nouveau possible en les
accompagnant à la construction de leur
parcours et à leur permettant de révéler
pleinement leur potentiel
en fait nous souhaitons valoriser
l'éducation comme une forme
d'investissement durable significative
et à très fort impact social auprès du
plus grand nombre car nous pensons que
tous les étudiants doivent avoir la
liberté de choisir leur avenir et nous
sommes convaincus que si les études
peuvent être parfois difficile leur
financement ne devrait jamais l'être
je vous remercie